[Music]
okay everybody this is my spoiler review
of Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania if
you haven't seen it yet check out my
spoiler free review linked below and
then come back to us after you've seen
the film so jumping into this I was
really really excited about this film I
am a huge Jonathan Majors fan I've been
saying since Lovecraft country this guy
is different he's special and he's
showing it here and he doesn't
disappoint his Kang I think it's more
the other way where the film to me
disappointed him and I said in my
spoiler-free review that there's so many
just pacing issues with this film and
the editing's weird and that you feel
like you're stuck in one setting I felt
like with the quantum realm we were just
in those three locations and it wasn't
really going anywhere else and it
subconsciously made me start to just
feel numb watching this film and I
didn't expect that because if I was
really engaged from the beginning when
when they got sent into the quantum
realm it was ready to go there was a
momentum building in the film I like
what they were building with Cassie and
Scott's relationship and then it just
kind of got stuck for me and I thought
that all these new Side characters and
you have William Jackson Harper here his
character I thought those are all very
forgettable and especially the character
who is this woman who's like Wants
Revenge and she felt very one note like
a lot of these Side characters did but
to one note you can get away with
outside characters if there's a little
more complexity which Marvels should be
able to do they're better quality than
that to have very like one node
characters going around so those felt
very rushed and not developed and I just
felt like this film had so much more
potential on its plate and then you see
too that it's another case where they
start doing a Rick and Morty writer they
have here because they're doing all this
like weird stuff with the Multiverse and
different timelines but you really felt
that Rick and Morty humor with the one
character that's pink there that's like
the jelly that's not my cup of tea I'm
not a big Rick and Morty fan so I just
didn't like it but maybe that's a bias
of mine but it was really felt just
ripped out of Rick and Morty cartoon and
that character was just placed in this
film so I wasn't crazy about that I'm
not against what they do with Modoc I
don't have any connection though to
Modoc like some people might have from
the comics or previous iterations I
enjoyed it with him I thought it was
fine it didn't blow me away but I
thought it was like more of the funny
moments in the film that landed I think
for me just watching this movie it was
bizarre that I feel like with Kang we
didn't get enough of a motivation for
him of why he was doing what he was
doing right now I wanted more into the
king the Conqueror right now and then it
was discouraging to me that he
disappeared at the end and then it's
supposed to get us excited with the post
credits of all these kangs but I still
wanted more of Kang the Conqueror and
knowing about what was going on with him
I still feel like I didn't learn much
about him before I moved to another Kang
so this is where I'm getting frustrated
now with all these multi-variants and
versions of people in the Marvel
Universe now and we've already had a lot
of Multiverse stuff now for a while so
it's disheartening to me as a Marvel fan
that we're still going with it you know
I'm over it already like I miss just
being invested in one type of person as
their character or one type of timeline
because I feel like if you keep
switching it up you don't get attached
to anything or anyone it's just changing
constantly and it's really heartening
Marvel I think right now and still is
the post credits right like I don't
think I'm ever excited when they set up
a show right like oh it's just Loki he's
gonna see Kang again we knew this right
or with the candy conqueror post credits
we knew there's gonna be multiple Kings
we already seen multiple Kings with he
who remains I think that's just not
something to get me excited
um so I don't know why there's people
jumping up and down about those post
credits doesn't make any sense to me I
thought though that Catherine Newton was
great as Cassie I thought the life she
brought to the screen was great and she
just was exciting there's an energy she
was bringing the film that the film
needed more of I think that Jonathan
Majors was incredible and come on that
scene when he first meets Scott and
Cassie I wanted more of that that was
Marvel doing something different than
even their tone it was intense it was
dark that's what you want for the new
big bad so why didn't they give him that
big ending at the end I mean no one in
all of Scott Lang's family passed away
he didn't really cause any big deaths or
change so that was really disappointing
if this is going to be the big bad for
the next couple films what what is this
setting up it still felt like just a
typical villain in the sense of he loses
at the end and the family wins with not
big consequences so I felt like it could
have had more power coming in it where
that one scene had that magic right
where it was letting Jonathan Majors do
his thing letting Kang be this
intimidating villain and for him to lose
at the end of the film I don't know I
didn't sit right with me especially
kicking off a phase we know how Marvel
works and having to set up a big bad
that will appear in other films to have
them lose makes me think well he's just
going to keep losing all these variants
like I don't know I I didn't like that I
wanted more of what we saw with him and
Cassie and Scott in the beginning of his
appearances and that there would be a
scene like that at the end and that
someone would pay the price someone
pretty easy decision too like Hank and
Janet they're older characters they've
been around like he could have even
asked one of them and I still think that
would have been enough but still you
could have and everyone's okay it's just
a happy safe very Marvel safe ending
which I didn't appreciate for this kind
of character and Kang and setting up
excitement and getting people back in
and setting up more emotions for this
big phase coming in this big villain
um I just didn't feel that and the film
it just feels so green screen to the
point where you sit and you're like what
am I watching right it I don't know I
just feel like in the hands of somebody
else this kind of weird film like a
James Gunner Taiko a TT would have done
a way better job this is Peyton
redirecting who do one and two where
Ant-Man wants me was fine but Ant-Man 2
I thought was one of the worst Marvel
films I've seen so it doesn't surprise
me when you see who's behind it you know
for the big thing this is kicking off
phase five that it was to me
disappointing in that sense and that it
was weak and again like I said there
wasn't great pacing in this film The
Flow was off I thought the best pacing
was in the beginning and then it decides
to show you some of Kang's past with
Janet but not enough to learn about Kang
himself in those moments either it was
just to learn about the plot and what
was happening with his device that he
needed really the McGuffin that he
needed so it didn't give enough Kang
backstory that we really really could
have used in this film and again more
motivation he talks about things we
don't know why he's so angry feeling the
way and if they're saying that for their
films that's the problem I have moral
films right now it's so much setup for
other stuff let something new and unique
feel here in this film pay off now I
don't want to wait for the next king
version I want this Kang version to be
awesome and you know leave a memory for
us but having said that I didn't hate
the film I thought it was a good film
and I didn't think it was bad I didn't
love it it's a 7.8 for me but that's
really raised by obviously Jonathan
Major's performance as Kang and
Catherine Newton here as Cassie and
Michelle Pfeiffer did great as Janet
this was her best performance in MCU to
date and they shed much so much more to
do here so I was really impressed with
his performances so I think that again
that brings it up and for me like I was
happy I saw it I'm happy I got to see
that amazing scene with Kang Scott and
Cassie when he first captures him I
still think there are some funny moments
but not a lot of funny moments that
landed either though like it wasn't a
lot of laughing in the theater I was
full with other critics it was pretty
quiet so it wasn't like the funniest
Marvel film and if it's not gonna be the
funniest Marvel film that's fine but if
you're gonna go darker tone stick with
it you know bring it like don't just
tease us with certain scenes and then go
the safe route like it all just ends up
nicely and happy at the end and yeah
they hint Scott you know oh Kang is
gonna come back but I want the one now
want something more now this is still
set up and yeah I I don't know I just
think this is not what Marvel needed
right now to get people back like as
invested as they were it just wasn't but
it was still good you know I didn't hate
it so I'm giving it a 7.8 and I still
think the biggest problem was again the
let down the quantum realm right just
thinking it was feeling like this one
setting not moving around enough or
feeling in different looking locations
but let me know what you thought of it
all spoilers welcome I read every card
I'm gonna try to spot as many as I can
please make sure to subscribe so you
don't miss one of my reviews I do movie
reviews TV reviews and celebrity
interviews and please follow me at Steve
Harley show on Twitter Instagram and
Tick Tock for more of me and I'll see
you next time